les nombres cortèges sont lancés ce
matin un petit peu partout je le disais
Rennes Marseille ont compté 7200
manifestants à Montpellier 14000 à
Toulouse 8000 à Lyon 7000 à Marseille ou
encore 5800 au Havre le message du jour
fait le parallèle entre 1789 et
aujourd'hui des têtes sont tombées ça va
recommencer est-il écrit la mobilisation
en province elle est encore plus forte
que dans les grandes métropoles ils
étaient 7000 à Marseille d'après la
police 90 000 pour les syndicats entre 3
et 10 000 à Strasbourg entre 6700 et
12000 à Rennes c'est un petit peu comme
la cocotte-minute mais on avait prévenu
Elisabeth borne avant même de commencer
les mobilisations c'est important qu'on
reste soudés solidaire les uns et les
autres dans la capitale comme dans tous
ces toutes ces villes de son cortèges
dans toute la France
solidaires Unis déterminé l'article 2
n'a pas été voté à l'Assemblée nationale
bah ça c'est parce qu'il y a des
mobilisations avec les députés
qu'ils disent ils sont obligés de tenir
compte de la vie de leurs électeurs je
dis pas que le jour de gloire est arrivé
mais enfin c'est l'heure de vérité c'est
le moment où on met la France à l'arrêt
et on doit arrêter Macron
que des tours de chasse des
échauffements avant ce qui va se passer
en mars et je peux vous dire que ce qui
nous attend à partir du 7 mars vont être
extrêmement fort on va réfléchir à tout
un tas d'initiatives qui nous
permettront de montrer notre combativité
et toujours en ayant à coeur de
respecter évidemment les biens et les
personnes mais de montrer que on est
capable de monter d'un cran si demain il
y a un blocage du pays ce sera de la
faute du gouvernement parce que le
gouvernement aura refusé d'entendre et
les arguments qui sont développés au
sein de ce Parlement et des arguments
qui sont développés par les Français
dans la rue on voit qu'il ne réalise pas
l'état de tension du pays et il n'a pas
pris conscience et par conséquent il y a
absolument besoin que par une action
aussi déterminée que celle d'aujourd'hui
mais sur tout celle du 7 mars que nous
avons le temps de préparer il lui soit
donné la leçon que qu'il doit recevoir
Emmanuel Macron a reçu aujourd'hui le
forum de l'islam de France le président
appel à redoubler d'efforts pour sortir
des interférences des gens n'ont c'est
la compétence sur le terrain pour en
dire cette personne est Imane n'est pas
une même cette personne peut prédé
qu'elle ne peut pas prédiquer et d'avoir
un système qui fait que quand des gens
qui prédiquent 10 des folies qui
menacent la République et Bafou la
religion qu'est-ce qui est l'Islam en
plus leur dire vous n'aurez plus le
droit de le faire la nupes annonce
retirée 90% de ses amendements soit
plusieurs milliers afin d'accélérer les
débats pour passer au vote du fameux
article sur le report de l'âge légal de
départ à 64 ans nous avons compris qu'un
certain nombre
de femmes et d'hommes de force souhaité
que nous puissions arriver à cette
discussion de l'article 7 pour démasquer
encore un peu plus les intentions de
chacune et de chacun sur ce texte nous
déposons une motion de censure parce que
au moment où nous nous parlons il est
évident que nous ne pourrons pas voter
le texte il faut bien donc voter il faut
que les députés s'expriment il faut que
ceux qui sont opposés à cette réforme
plus le faire et bien nous leur en
donnons la possibilité en déposant une
leçon de censure en prenant trois heures
de plus sur les débats dont elle sait
que à aucun moment cette notion de
censure ne peut être majoritaire c'est
un coup de main donné au gouvernement
qui ne demandait rien d'autre que
d'avoir un vote à la fin de ce de ce
débat donc bravo pour elle elle est en
train de les aider comme elle le fait
depuis le début si vous allez commencer
à 15 ans 17 ans et 20 ans vos cotiserez
un an mais si vous avez commencé à 14
ans 16 ans 18 ans rien ne change ce
ministre on n'y comprend plus rien je
vais vous dire c'est normal non mais
c'est pas normal et j'ai rien contre
personne
je dis simplement que nous sommes dans
un système de retraite qui est d'une
complexité sans nom qu'il a toujours été
l'actrice américaine Raquel Welch sexe
symbole des années 60 et 70 est morte
paisiblement après une courte maladie a
fait savoir sa famille on est sur le
coup politique de Marine Le penché